what were the things that you were pre
planning for you've always talked about
you know when you said that with your
Kickstarter campaign you front-loaded
all the work so what did you front load
in terms of this short film you know the
casting was the big thing I cast a great
actor Lyle Pina as the recruiter and he
I knew him because he was the the town
boss in my web series from several years
ago and you're Lionel is a trooper he's
been in a number of movies and I felt
that having him on board from day one
would really help us as far as you know
being able to do a casting call and
being able to read the two of our two
leads together to see what kind of
chemistry they had as opposed to just
you know with the casting director with
myself so that was kind of the big thing
you know I knew this is going to be a
film that was made or broken in the
performances especially with Curtis cook
jr. as the basketball player it's a very
nuanced role that you have to be able to
play you have to be able to be
believable it's a basketball player both
from physicality of playing sport but
also from your your attitude and the way
you carry yourself you have to show that
you're a highly competitive athlete but
your performance also has to have a
certain vulnerability again go see the
short if you haven't seen it a spoiler
alert but you know he's um you know he's
sandbagging he's you know he's playing
he's playing dad he's playing possum a
little bit so you have to be able to
show vulnerability as well so that to me
was the big thing was was finding the
right actor and you know Curtis showed
up was the only active reread that
didn't have a head shot and just just
nailed it and the rest of the day we
know is it was who can be who can be
Curtis and then I did a call back so I
think a lot of the front loading the
preparation you don't want to get on set
and find out and you know find an
unpleasant surprise so to me this is a
basketball movie that needs to have
convincing basketball one of the
problems that you're faced with when
you're making is say a hollywood sports
film is that this after Lee wants to be
in it but maybe that actor can't
actually who so then you're you have a
guy who just can't
has a broken looking a jump shot you
know you're cutting to the room and the
ball goes in this is expressly not that
film you know this is a movie that I
think has to appeal both to indie film
fans and real basketball fans as a fan
and player myself so the casting call
the callbacks are scheduled to be two
days later in a casting room and I just
I couldn't have that so on monday for
our tuesday callbacks i'm calling gyms
in manhattan i standing to preserve an
hour in your gym day before you know
less than 24 hours notice and i managed
to find place so we did our callbacks
there so not only did we reread you know
full scenes and really sort of have our
our best actors come back but i also was
able to set the actors and play
one-on-one against each other and see
what they could and couldn't do and see
who really could handle the ball and who
could shoot and find out you know what
they what they can and can't do in the
sense that then i could could direct
towards their strengths on the court and
not be wasting time on set finding out
that oh I've written a scene I've
written something for you to do that
you're not very good at but you're
really convincing it's other things so
we're going to waste a bunch of time
shooting this one thing and then making
an adjustment to go to this other thing
so that way I can walk on set already
having a choreographed in my head and
you know I'm a web series the west side
there's a lot of action there's
gunfights there's a lot of after effects
there's always special effects in there
and we didn't do a single storyboard I
feel very comfortable knowing screen
direction I've been editing for 12 years
you know I think we're doing visual
effects or something I would definitely
want a storyboard for those purposes but
I feel very comfortable walking into a
set knowing where to put the camera and
how to get continuous action so it was
more the front loading of the
performance and the ability to play the
sport and knowing what was going to
happen on screen more so that it was the
front loading of storyboarding and
previz or anything like that I did a
shot list that was my main planning and
then on set I ended up having to kill a
lot of the shots of course to make the
day
that we were doing you know seven and a
half pages in a day or something
including you know plus plus basketball
action so I think the front loading is
really just making sure that you know
trying to minimize the number of
unpleasant surprises that you're going
to face on the day
you